بدوره دع الرئيس
الفرنسيين لتقديم المساعده والضغط على
روسيا لانهاء حربها ضد هذا البلد وقال
مكرون تعليقا على المبادره الصينيه ان
السلام ممكن اذا نجح في وقف العدوان
الروسي وانسحبت القوات الروسيه وتم احترام
سياده الاقليميه واراده الشعب الاوكراني
واشار الرئيس الفرنسي في تصريحات ادلى بها
اليوم الى انه سيزور الصين مطلع نيسان
ابريل المقبل
من جهه قال نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي
ديمتري ان بلاده توجه اعداء من 50 دوله
هدفهم خنق روسيا ومسحها من على وجه الارض
اضاف في مقال بصحيفه الدفاع الوطني انه لا
جدوى من الضغط على روسيا مشيرا الى ان
صناعه العسكريه قادره على انتاج كل ما
يحتاجون اليه للتصدي لاي عدوان واوضح ان
التاريخ يعيد نفسه بعد الذكرى 80 للانتصار
في معركه ستالينغراد حيث توجه روسيا مره
اخرى امبراطوريه من اعداء مختلفين تضم
الفاشين الجدد الاوكرانيين والاوروبيين
والولايات المتحده
والانجلوساكسون واتباعهم على حد تعبيره